what is that thing that's creepy
this looks like a ramen this is just
like ramen noodles I don't really like
them it's good it's really good I give
it a 2 out of 5 - I give it a 5 I guess
what I don't want to eat again
can I take these home with me
in the safe of a koala mmm-hmm I like
that one I was using they can make these
in California and a bit off his poor
little head I'm sorry I would love this
as my dessert it'll be it's really good
tastes like a chocolate rice krispies
tastes like milk chocolate it's really
really good
I don't like that taste it's 5 out of 5
I'll give this a 5 it inch 5 out of 5
I've never eaten anything flavored like
syllabus whoa that's my friend so scared
to eat these cuz in a lot this is
poisonous for humans in California and
like this do one no bite Oh
I
I think it's pretty good but also kind
of not if I were a koala I wouldn't
really like to eat eucalyptus I really
like this one
thank you what oh I've heard of this bit
is it Vegemite Lola I do that I like
visiting yeah ah so this doesn't really
Pleasant me spicy weird butter it's
really like sour Oh
mmm still let the chocolate does they
like Fletcher something was oh thank you
my bet you pilots it's good that you
might stood I think we're steady and
snacks are actually good put when you
look at the bag it doesn't really look
good put them when you try it it's good
that's why that's why they say don't
judge the book by its cover
you are most Australian in hey Vegemite
on toast everybody they do well probably
out there they probably like it but not
people here
what's the pop some people you like it
bit me I don't